hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar see digitial testing conundrums
guidelines and diagnostic stewardship
presented by dr. Karen C Carol and dr.
Masako Nozawa I'm Kristy dual of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by BD BD is a global
medical technology company that is
advancing the world of health by
improving medical discovery diagnostics
and the delivery of care to learn more
about our sponsor please visit molecular
diagnostics dot b decom /bb
- max - system forward slash
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event today is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of your
presentation window or let us knows are
having a problem by using the ask a
question box
this presentation is educational and the
sopla is continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right of
the presentation window to follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speakers dr. Karen C
Carol professor of pathology and
director of the Division of Medical
Microbiology
at the Johns Hopkins University School
of Medicine also presenting today is dr.
Masako Mizusawa assistant professor
section of infectious diseases
department of internal medicine at
University of Missouri Kansas City we're
complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. Carol dr. mrs. Salwa you may both
now begin your presentation
okay Thank You Christy for that
introduction hello everyone and thank
you for participating here is our
disclosure slide and I just want to
mention that some of these companies do
manufacture tests for the detection of C
difficile so we hope today that at the
conclusion of this presentation you will
have learned about the current
challenges with C difficile testing the
IDSA che guidelines for diagnostic
testing and most importantly
interventions to improve c difficile
testing the first pathological
description of pseudomembranous colitis
actually came out of Johns Hopkins in
1893 the patient was a 22 year old woman
described by William Osler
as a miserable emaciated creature in
wretched physical condition she
underwent resection of a gastric tumor
and did well until the 10th
post-operative day when it was noted
that she was having bloody diarrhea and
unfortunately she died five days later
on autopsy she had what was described at
the time as a dip the riddick membrane
involving the terminal ileum and the
colon and if you look at the figure this
is the original photo micrograph of the
histologic sections from this patient it
was almost a hundred years later however
before the link between pseudomembranous
colitis C difficile and its toxins was
established between 1975 and 1980 there
were several groups involved in the
early work sinn fein goals group John
Bartlett's group in 1977 Bartlett and
colleagues established a hamster model
and this proved to be a very useful
model for disgust for studying the
pathogenesis of C difficile with this
model they demonstrated that clindamycin
associated colitis which it was called
at the time was due to a toxin producing
strain of Clostridium
taewin Chang was the biologist in the
group who characterized a cytopathic
assay Nancy Taylor was the biologist in
the group and she described toxin a and
enterotoxin and toxin B the cytotoxic
and in 1978 the authors published the
landmark paper in the New England
Journal of Medicine that firmly
established the fact that patients with
pseudomembranous colitis associated with
antibiotics had C difficile toxin genic
c difficile excuse me the next slide
Emin straights on the c difficile spider
toxin assay that was developed by p1
check on the left-hand side of the panel
you can see a nun inoculated fibroblast
cell line to which he applied filtrates
of the stool of the patients with
pseudomembranous colitis and in the
middle panel you can see the
characteristic cytopathic effect with
rounding and density of the nuclei and
speculations and this is very
characteristic now of this toxigenic
effect of c difficile and he was able to
actually neutralize the cytopathic
effect by using C stored le antitoxin
the researchers use this assay to study
the epidemiology of c difficile disease
between 1978 and 1980 and in the box on
the right hand side you can see some of
that data so in patients that had
confirmed pseudomembranous colitis due
to antibiotic associated diarrhea almost
all of them had C difficile toxins in
their stool however only 27 percent of
patients with antibiotic associated
diarrhea and no confirmed
pseudomembranous colitis had seated the
sale toxin in their stool also an
important observation is that antibiotic
recipients with no diarrhea could also
excrete C difficile toxin in their stool
and in this particular study was about
2%
in addition the authors also confirm the
earlier results of Hall and O tool these
were as you may recall the individuals
who name the organism as bacillus diffa
sillas in healthy infants they
demonstrated that 27% of these
individuals had seeded the sealed toxins
in their stool and hence the
recommendation not to test infants less
than two years of age routinely for C
difficile without compelling clinical
and epidemiologic information so the
cell culture neutralization assay became
the standard reference method proceeded
at the seal diagnosis it was 100%
sensitive in the hamster model in humans
however false negatives were seen due to
procedural problems such as over
dilution false positives were also seen
to be done to occur as a result of
procedural errors in the filtration and
dilution steps also false positives
could be attributed to asymptomatic
patients who Harbor toxin producing
strains it's important to point out that
CCNA was never standardized for use in
clinical labs it's not easy to perform
it's not rapid and not reproducible and
therefore clinical labs look for
alternative methods to perform testing
for this disease this led to the
manufacture of enzyme immunoassays which
use monoclonal or polyclonal antibodies
to detect toxin interestingly enzyme
amino acid development began soon after
the discovery of C difficile in its
toxins but it was observed to be tenfold
less sensitive than cider toxin testing
and hence was not pursued at the time as
a viable option for diagnosis the first
antibiotic ID base C difficile assay was
marketed in 1986 this was the culture at
brand rabid latex test it was designed
to detect toxin a in 30 minutes which
would have been a fantastic advance
however what it actually did
it was glutamate dehydrogenase the
common antigen found in toxin positive
and talked to negative C difficile other
commercial toxin a and and toxin B
assays followed however as this clinical
study again performed at Hopkins
demonstrated clinically enzyme
immunoassays were shown to lack
sensitivity this study was performed by
dr. Bartlett and dr. u Cavanaugh be on
268 non oncology patients and the
authors observed that when using an e IA
only the accuracy for detection of C
difficile was only 72% but they could
improve detection by sending multiple
samples on the same patients to
compensate for the sub optimal AI a
performance and so the institutional
practice at Hopkins and actually other
laboratories I'm told became stools for
C deaf times three I arrived Hopkins in
2002 and shortly thereafter I began to
get a series of complaints that prompted
us to reevaluate the C difficile AIA
tests in use in the lab at that time and
much to our dismay we found that the
sensitivity of that assay had fallen to
38% and therefore we switched to the
cell culture cytotoxicity neutralization
assay literature from others followed
which duplicated our results and in 2008
and 2009 two wonderful reviews were
published on the six tox a B test in use
at the time which demonstrated that none
of them met the acceptability criteria
which the authors defined as the
sensitivity of 90% and a false positive
rate of less than or equal to three
percent and so enzyme immunoassays were
declared sub optimal so what was what
was happening during this time well
these two studies published in the New
England Journal of 2000 2005
demonstrated that in North America we
were seeing the emergence of epidemic
toxin variant strain
of c.difficile in the study by cliff
McDonald 50% of 187 isolates were found
to be nap one strains buy pulsed field
gel electrophoresis and Ryba type o 27
compared to the historical nap one
strains these new strains were
fluoroquinolone resistant they also
seemed to be hyper producers of toxin in
addition to that also hyper spore you
laters and so they were more easily
disseminated throughout the hospital
environment and also cause more severe
disease the increased severity of
disease caused by these strains was very
much apparent in the Quebec study among
twelve different hospitals where 6.5
percent of patients required intensive
care and 1.9 percent required colectomy
more importantly the 30-day attributable
mortality in that study was six point
nine percent whereas the baseline was
one point five percent so clearly this
emergence of this strain refocused
attention on diagnostic testing so many
laboratories were looking for
alternatives to e is glutamate
dehydrogenase assays began to appear
again this detects highly conserved
common antigen present in both toxin
positive and toxin negative strains
there were two formats that became
available the first format was a solid
phase microtiter plate assay which we
implemented in our laboratory and then
later on lateral flow devices that
combine gdh detection with toxin a and B
detection became available and this
actually simplified testing so gdh was
incorporated into multi-step algorithms
and meta-analyses showed a greater than
90% sensitivity for the gdh components
of these tests so we implemented a
two-step algorithm at Johns Hopkins that
you see here on if the sample was gdh
positive then we confirm
firmed that it was a toxin producer
using the c.difficile cytotoxicity
neutralization assay but the problem
with that was that the time to a
positive result could require up to 72
hours and so this really wasn't a good
solution of course now with the lateral
flow assays the time deposit if 'ti is
much quicker however we realize that we
needed a sensitive test in a more rapid
test so we started thinking about
molecular testing an early reports using
PCR appeared in the literature in 1991
these were n detection assays because we
were dealing with stole the extractions
were quite cumbersome and we saw a cross
reactivity with other Clostridium
species in those early PCR assays
however a decade later we had DNA
extraction methods from fecal samples
that improved we have real-time
platforms which became available and the
analytical sensitivity of PCR was
compared to CCNA was much higher 10 200
times more sensitive for example in some
in many studies the analytical
specificity also improved the first
fda-cleared platform became available in
2009 and this was the bebe genome assay
and we did implement this assay in our
clinical laboratory now however we have
this embarrassment of riches as
demonstrated by on this slide the last
time I looked at this there were more
than 13 fda-cleared nucleic acid tests
available for the detection of c
difficile toxins in stool shortly after
we implemented the PCR test in our
laboratory we began to get lots of
questions from clinicians these were
very thoughtful questions and I think
they're still relevant today some of the
questions were practical these assays
detect genes encoding toxins and not the
toxin itself so can they reliably
predict disease and what will be the
impact on CDI rates when switching from
an insensitive test like see I ate and I
did four
warned our infection control team that
they were going to see an increase in
their PCR rates I'm not going to talk
about theoretical concerns although I
think these do need to be considered and
then in terms of other questions will
the use of Nats lead to reductions in C
difficile transmission I will talk a
little bit about that what will be the
impact on patient care and Arnett's
cost-effective and there has been at
least one paper in the literature early
on that demonstrated that gnats can be
very cost effective in terms of the
diagnosis of suit of the seal so this
brings us to infection control in the
national healthcare safety network so a
positive C difficile test taking greater
than three days after admission
constitutes Hospital onset CDI lab ID
event when this first this requirement
first came out any positive C difficile
test was considered a lab ID event
however in 2018 the national healthcare
safety network updated their
requirements and to accommodate two-step
testing and if a laboratory is using a
two-step test you only need to report
this as a lab ID event if both tests are
positive so this does help those
laboratories that are using a two-step
algorithm however it does not help those
laboratories who have chosen to use NAT
alone as a single test this was designed
to be a patient safety metric however it
does not incorporate chart review or
take into consideration patient symptoms
and of course it is greatly influenced
by test characteristics and ordering
behaviors in an institution so I do have
permission to show you this slide from
our infection control team and what it
illustrates is if you are going from a
relatively insensitive test such as you
cna to a nucleic acid test this will
give the appearance of an increase in
your transmission rate um however what
what
it really is pointing out as better
detection and so we did observe that in
our hospital environment but what that
what happened in the year after we
implemented the PCR because we were
doing PCR more frequently and because it
was a more sensitive test patients were
getting placed on contact precautions
much more quickly and with improvements
in hand hygiene and other infection
control bundles we actually saw a true
drop in the number of feet of the seal
on transmissions when our infection
control team looked did some chart
review the other observations that they
made is that when you apply to clinical
definition the actual transmission rate
was even lower and this suggested
perhaps there was some over utilization
of the c difficile nat test and if you
look at 2016 when we implemented the
epic product project that dr. M users
alwah will be addressing in the second
half of this presentation we were
actually able to reduce transmission
even more so on the next several slides
talks about some of the literature that
informed the IDSA Shea guidelines and
this study by uber key it all
highlighted the importance of clinical
symptoms in assay interpretation this
was a study of nine assays including
three Nats and they used to reference
standards with and without symptoms what
was nice about this study is that it was
prospective and they use patient
interviews and physical exams in terms
of interpreting some of the test results
not surprisingly gnats had the highest
sensitivity but the lowest specificity
of all the test methods and the
specificity and positive predictive
value for all assays increased when
clinical symptoms were ignored the
specificity excuse me there were two
other very important observations
thirty-six percent of patients did not
have clinically significant diarrhea
again suggesting over utilization of
sting and 20% of patients were on a
laxative at the time of testing when we
looked at our rates at Johns Hopkins
shockingly it was 44% on some of our
medical units there were two other very
important studies that are that did help
inform the IDSA guidelines the first
study came out of the UK by planche at
all this is a multicenter observational
study of seeked at the seal infection
and the authors intended to validate
tests based on clinical outcomes they
compared for commercial assays IHG D H
and PCR to to reference methods spider
toxin tests and talk to Jenny culture
and what they observed is that patients
who were CC A+ had higher mortality and
more severe disease than culture
positive or PCR positive toxin negative
patients and that the best predictor of
C difficile disease was jak was actually
the site or toxin test but because of
the problems that I highlighted with
CCNA their final recommendation was to
use a two and three-step gdh based
combination test and they saw this as
the best option for patient care and so
the standard of care and they in the UK
is to use a two-step algorithm based
upon gdh and a quote sensitive toxin aia
test the second study was performed by
Polish at all in the United States this
was a prospective observational study of
over 1,400 patients they compared toxin
aia which was the standard of care in
the institution at that time to pcr and
they asked the question who talked to
the negative PCR positive patients
required treatment and if you look at
the second bullet point the u toxin
negative PCR positive patients had
milder and shorter duration of symptoms
58.7% of those patients were not
retested indicating that the physician
likely thought that they didn't have
disease in the first place and then only
13% actually received a four
full course of treatment in spite of the
negative toxin test 18 of 19 seed if
related complications and deaths
occurred in toxin positive patients only
although there was one death in a
patient who was toxin negative PCR
positive who did not get treated because
of that test so on the flip side however
there are several studies albeit they
are smaller studies that actually show a
lack of correlation of toxin positivity
with disease severity and what most of
these studies have in common
is that the patients are
immunocompromised in the Guerrero study
which was done in a VA a third of the
patients with CDI would have been missed
with an enzyme immunoassay only and 21%
of those patients had severe C difficile
infection in the Humphrey study the
presence of toxin did not correlate with
disease severity in the cultists study
also there was no difference in severity
or mortality between between groups
although the toxin positive patients had
higher recurrence rates and in the Erb
study ei e ia positive and E I a
negative but toxigenic culture positive
patients also had similar outcomes that
study was actually kind of interesting
they did not look at nucleic acid
amplification tests but what they did
observe is that in this patient
population if they had relied upon e IA
only they would have missed a
significant proportion of patients who
had moderate to severe disease so now we
come to the guidelines so the IDSA and
che professional societies to put
together a 14-member panel that examined
new information published between 2009
and 2016
they used the grading of recommendations
assessment development and evaluation
system to assess the strength of
evidence for each recommendation
the new guidelines also included
pediatric specific recommendations that
were absent in the 2010 version and the
guidelines address the epidemiology
infection control diagnosis and
treatment of seed at the seal disease so
this slide speaks to the guidelines on
diagnosis the first recommendation is if
no institutional guidelines for stool
submission are in place then
laboratories are directed to use a stool
toxin test as part of a multi-step
algorithm so you can see this could be a
glutamate dehydrogenase plus toxin dia
and again the guidelines specify a quote
sensitive toxin aia you can do g d h+
toxin a IA and perform net if the EIA is
negative and the GD H is positive or you
can begin with an at and then confirm
the net positives with toxin
test if and the second recommendation
States however is if there are pre
agreed institutional criteria for stool
submission then a NAT test alone may be
used so what did the committee have in
mind here well what we had in mind in
terms of these institutional criteria
were whether or not there were stool
rejection criteria by the laboratory for
stools that were not liquid or soft and
also whether or not the institution had
a way of assessing whether patients
receiving laxatives and other particular
criteria that are described in the in
the guidelines in addition to these two
recommendations the guidelines also
state not to routinely perform CDI
testing in children with diarrhea twelve
months of age or younger and also to
consider excluding other causes of
diarrhea first in children one to two
years of age before testing proceeded to
the seal so with that I am going to end
my session and dr. Musacchio Miyazawa
will talk about what laboratories
do to improve a test utilization so that
perhaps a single used nap might be
appropriate for a particular setting so
with that dr. Meece Rosario Miyazawa I
will turn this over to you thank you
Thank You dr. Carroll
hello everyone from here I would like to
discuss what laboratories can do to
improve city of sotas utilization
unfortunately we currently do not have a
diagnostic test that can reliably
differentiates it affection from
colonization if the tests were not
ordered appropriately we may detect
Eliza death which can lead to
unnecessary CDI treatment unnecessary
hospital stay and associated healthcare
cost it can also lead to increase in the
number of hospital also stated cases
reported to CMS through national
healthcare safety Network
common pitfalls instead of the diagnosis
include testing series for patients on
laxatives testing fold to repeat in
tests in the short interval and testing
for cure and all of them can lead to
detection or colitis so it is important
for collisions to know when to test and
when not to touch so that they can
select appropriate patients positive so
testing
one of the solutions to overcome those
pitfall is to form a diagnostic
management team and break down the
communication barriers between
clinicians and laboratories so that we
can work together to improve the tasks
utilization and the quality of diagnosis
other team
there are many interventions to improve
test utilization computerized clinical
decision support CCDs is one of them
CCDs is a health information technology
to assist clinicians decision making and
implement evidence-based practice by
providing diagnostic and treatment
recommendations it can be in a variety
of forms such as pop-up alert
information displays or links or
targeted highlighting of well burned
data
in general allergen onto the only
modestly effective up this due to alert
fatigue caused by excessive numbers of
were knees and overwritten alert
in addition bias unintended consequences
have been observed after introduction of
CC SDS alert systems now I would like to
share our experience with introduction
of CCDs for city of testing at Johns
Hopkins
sicinius in electronic health records
facility testing was introduced at three
hospitals in the John Hopkins Health
System initially at Johns Hopkins
Hospital in October 2016 4 by two
affiliated community hospital our County
General Hospital in December 2016 and
Suburban Hospital in January 2017 our
electronic health record was epic City
still testing used in Johns Hopkins
Health System is a simple test algorithm
using detection of TCDD gene by nucleic
acid amplification criteria for
inappropriate resting in CCDF laxative
administration within 48 hours
negative sister test without within
seven days and positive series test
without within 14 days of test ordering
if a third-order beats any of those
criteria best practice alerts are
activated and providers and require you
to obtain test approval to process the
order our best practice alerts have two
component the first PPA works as a soft
stop and the second BPA works other hard
stop and I will explain how they work in
the next slide
in order to ensure that the intervention
did not cause any unexpected harm on
patient care but those effective chart
we do was conducted for all three
hospitals for three months after
introduction of CCDs this is the first
PPA screen physicians are offered
multiple opportunities to change their
mind and not to pursue testing in this
yellow box physicians will see the
instruction to send only a liquid stool
and test only where the patient have
three or more unformed - within 24 hours
criteria for in a purpose you're
expecting are listed here as well if all
the providers would like to learn more
about appropriative testing they can
consult this one-minute guide and if
they click on this link it will take
them to a three page long PDF document
about appropriate serious testing with
scientific evidence
lastly here is the best practice alert
with a stop sign and the specific
criteria that activated the alert in
this case it was part of a test result
within 14 days here providers are
instructed to call the micro lab to
obtain approval if they still thinks it
is so testing is necessary for their
patient on the right lower corner there
is a sign button
oddly provided would be able to
overwrite the BPA however if they click
on the sign button and try to overwrite
the first PPA the second BBS screen pops
up and informs the providers in more
obvious way that they cannot proceed
further and they need to call the micro
lab to obtain tests approval
by calling the micro lab ordering
providers can obtain a secret test code
for another test order called a booth
micro Baljeet SC
this is a screen for this new test order
they will be asked to enter a name of a
technologies to approve the tests here
the approval request is never rejected
as long as they make an effort to call
the micro lab to obtain approval the
micro lab keeps a call log to document
when and through code for approval for
which patients
the disco process control chart that was
generated to compare the average weekly
number of the city circus before and
after the introduction of CCDs the red
vertical line represents initiation of
the intervention a solid line with a dot
represents the number of set of sotas
orders per thousand patient days in a
dotted model with a triangle represents
the number of positive sisters per
thousand impatient day we found that the
average weekly number of services such
orders per thousand an impatient date
significantly decreased after the
introduction of CCDs Johns Hopkins
Hospital Powell County General Hospital
in suburban hospital so introduction of
CCDs led to reduction of inappropriate
serious testing orders in both academic
and community hospital settings we also
look at the number of BPA activation
that resulted in completion of approved
test completion of approved test means
that tradition called microwatt to
obtain approval ordered authoritative
steps with a secret test code sent to
specimen to the micro lab and tests were
completed the task completion rate was
thirty four point five percent at Johns
Hopkins Hospital 11.1% at Howard County
General Hospital and 12.4% at Suburban
Hospital which suggests that many
providers eventually decided not to
pursue testing after they activated BPA
we also evaluate a situation to reaction
to the first BPA and the second BPA
separately the first BPA compliance
suggests that provider so the first BPA
screen and decided not to test without
cooking on the sign button to obtain
attempt overriding alert the second BPA
compliance suggest that providers
accepted over running the first BPA by
clicking on the sign button and
activated the second BPA but stopped at
that point and did not obtain approval
to pursue testing approval obtained
suggest that they did not fall BPA at
all and pursued testing
at first interaction
15.4% of providers will confine with the
first BPA fifty-seven point seven
percent were not compliant with the
first BPA but confinement with the
second BPA and twenty six point nine
percent did not follow BPA and obtained
test approval
in the retrospective chart we do there
was no significant difference in age
gender and c-d-i risk factors between
patients for firm test approvals pursued
and those fulfilled test approval was
not pursued the most common criteria
that activated BPA was laxative use
within 48 hours the most common reason
for pursuing test approval was diarrhea
for by leukocytosis of note the
proportion of test orders that met
clinical definition of CF so infection
was 56% at Johns Hopkins Hospital 50%
Howard County General Hospital and 54
percent at Suburban Hospital these
results suggest that many providers
ordered C disgusting when their patient
had one or two bowel movements within 24
hours
we also evaluated safety outcomes of the
patients for whom test approval was not
pursued in order to make sure that those
patients did not have adverse events
associated with CCDs there was no delay
in CDI diagnosis there was no epic CDI
treatment without testing and there was
no colitis of unknown origin that could
have been undiagnosed CDI
of note 21% of the approved tests were
eventually not performed due to lack of
stool specimen submission
so I just wanted to share a modern
example of CCDs for set of so tossing in
a different EHR system because your
institution may not have epic this EHR
is Cerner and when I started working out
my current institution which is
University of Missouri Kansas City after
finishing my Medical Microbiology
fellowship at Johns Hopkins the repeat
testing restriction by itself already
existed as a rule built in laboratory
order system so I suggested adding CCD
as the incorporates medication
administration record to check for box
abuse in still counts on the flowsheet
for frequency of diarrhea but it was not
visible by the Cerner team at the time
instead Turner was able to create this
CCD as in a relatively short period of
time when providers order series of
testing two drop-down boxes are shown
for them to answer yes or no to the
questions regarding must abuse and
frequency of Bustos as long as they
select either yes or no they can click
on the sign button the correct answer is
yes two three or more loose stools
within 24 hours and no two laxatives use
within 48 hours and then baking process
the orders however if they select the
wrong answer
the alert pops up to inform providers
that the test order is not appropriate
there is a sign button here as these
providers could still over like the
order but if they click on OK on the
pop-up alert the screen disappears with
the order that were working that they
were working on and if they still want
to pursue testing they have to start
over from the beginning
this CCDs is not exactly a hard stop
because providers can process it if so
test orders as long as they know what to
select for those questions in the
drop-down boxes but even at least remind
the providers of checking laxative use
and frequency of diarrhea for
appropriate testing lastly I would like
to mention briefly about one more
potential intervention to improve test
utilization it is Sidda specie of cycle
threshold values there are many there
are multiple studies that evaluated
correlation between the board and cutoff
CT values and positive top CIA in or
CCNA testing results as well as
correlation between CP values and
clinical outcomes such as disease
severity modality recurrence and all
year some studies found significant
correlation where's iris found no
significant correlation given
conflicting data on clinical utility
validation studies at all institution
would be necessary for introduction of
PCR cycle threshold as a predictor of
free toxins
the digital test diagnostic stewardship
interventions include repeat testing
restrictions in specific intervals by
creating rules in the lab of the orders
system each all based computerized
clinical decision support to prevent
inappropriate expressing orders based on
repeat testing restriction rules
laxative use or frequency of dire year
test order cancellation after 24 to 48
hours if no stool specimen arrives in
the laboratory so that the specimen
won't be sent later despite the
patient's clinical improvement just
because the orders remain active for
nurses reporting predicted presence of
free toxin based on CD values could be
considered if validation studies at your
own institution ensured clinical utility
in summary the difícil continues to
cause substantial disease burden the
diagnostic test pendulum has swung from
toxin tests to molecular assays with a
call to reinstitute toxin testing
clinicians should partner with
laboratories to ensure appropriate test
utilization with orders of the test
method thank you for your attention
and now we would like to open up for
questions
thank you dr. Carolyn dr. mrs. Salwa for
your informative presentation yes it is
now time to start the live Q&A portion
of our webinar
now while dying while dr. Carroll and
dr. mrs. all are going over the
questions I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit those questions
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
now we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for and those questions we are
unable to answer live and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be answered via the email address
you provided at the time of registration
ok let's get started
our first question we've got some great
questions coming in let's start with
this one okay it's a little long so I'm
bare with me could you please speak to
the current discussion about gdh toxin
discordant reflex to PCR versus PCR
positive reflex to toxin and only toxin
result reported this is for new this is
for NHSN CMS reporting now we use GBH
toxin reflex accordance to PCR and we
report final result results of PCR test
we also have laboratory protocols in
place to evaluate stool consistency max
it is repeat testing and this is used
for rejection physician must call lab to
get approval to override cancellations
dr. Carroll or dr. Mizusawa would you
like to comment on this sure this is dr.
Carroll um so first I want to
congratulate you for having protocols in
place to reduce inappropriate test
utilization that's excellent so you know
I I think the algorithms that you have
mentioned are all approved by the IDSA
guidelines I think the gdh toxin
Dischord it reflex to PCR is probably
the the more popular one and the one
that frankly makes
most sense to me you can also it is also
a guide in the guidelines that you can
start with nucleic acid testing and
reflux - toxin in our environment
however I would have concerns about only
reporting those that are toxin positive
and PCR negative I feel that especially
if you have already taken steps to
improve the pretest probability in a
complex hospital environment where
you're not just dealing with a general
patient population but you if you have a
large number of immunocompromised
patients I am of the belief that E is
not sufficient in that that patient
population so I so I don't really favor
that particular algorithm that's my
personal opinion the guidelines however
do allow you to do that
thank you dr. Carol now my next question
please explain the rationale behind the
two-step algorithm it was still not this
will still not differentiate between CD
infection versus colonization
um I agree I agree dude so I I have
never really understood that you know
even though we had implemented it in the
interim between the availability of
nucleic acid tests and and you know we
abandon our AIA testing so I agree
thank to you okay let's move on to our
next question so many great questions
coming in how about okay this one is dr.
mrs. solid this is for you what criteria
did laboratory staff use when called for
test order approval so there was no
criteria for approval there they don't
but the technicians technologies are not
going to obtain any credible information
they just need to pull the mic lab and
ask for the approval and then everybody
gets approved thank you our next
question do you have any recommendations
for when both pcrc death and enteric
pathogen panels are ordered pathogen
panel includes c-diff should the fetus
run first and further testing
discontinued if c-diff is positive
so I'm presuming you're talking about
the enteric pathogen panel test that our
GI panel tests that includes c difficile
since the laboratory really cannot make
an assessment about clinical relevance
in those scenarios I really feel like
there should be some discussion with
with the clinicians about the
appropriate use of the panel tests that
do include C difficile I know that some
institutions who have embraced the GI
panel the broad-based GI panels have
elected not to report the c diff and
really offer c diff testing independent
of the GI panel so I I think it's
difficult for me to answer the question
directly without knowing you know the
clinical circumstances surrounding how
the testing is performed in that
particular laboratory so I think this is
a decision that the lab cannot make by
itself I think there needs to be some
discussion with gi infectious disease
stewardship infection control anyone
who's willing to sort of help you with
those algorithms
thank you dr. Carol now in seeking
approval from the micro lab when a
provider receives a hard stop when
trying to order seed of testings what
questions are the micro lab staff asking
of the provider
so again the they do not obtain any
clinical information and ages obtain the
name of the provider who hold the
microwave and the the patient that they
would like to test seated for that
that's it I they don't need to explain
why they still would like to appreciate
testing
thank you dr. Mississauga our next
question can you speak more to why you
decided to continue with NAT testing do
you use just Matt or do you use a toxin
test as well so we since we had sort of
studied this in our environment and we
we were aware that we were having over
utilization issues particularly with
respect to patients on laxatives we
elected to try to improve the pretest
probability of nucleic acid testing as
opposed to confirming a sensitive test
with an insensitive test and not address
over utilization issues at all and let
me just back up a little bit and let you
know how we arrived at this decision
this is not a decision that I made
independently when the Kalinda paper by
Chris polish was published I assembled a
multidisciplinary group that included GI
a GI physician several infectious
disease specialists who had an interest
in enteric pathogens pediatric
infectious disease infection control
team some of our community hospitals and
out of microbial stewardship so it was a
big group of people we had probably 30
plus individuals who attended the
meeting we reviewed the paper we felt
that there were some limitations in the
paper we also felt that the patient
population was perhaps a little
different
than our patient population and oh I
forgot oncology there was an oncologist
at the there as well and it was the
consensus that you know I sort of gave
you the history of testing at the Johns
Hopkins Hospital was the consensus that
given our patient population we would
like to try to improve the positive
predictive value of what we consider the
most sensitive test for detection of C
difficile disease and therefore we would
work on trying to come up with an epic
solution an educational campaign and
then some hard stops surrounding some of
the areas where we appreciated that
there was over utilization for example
testing patients who were on laxatives
so so we so that was our journey you
know we started with the the working
group on you saw the little slide of the
huddle with a big huddle and then dr.
Clare Rock who is of our infection
control specialists really grabbed us by
the horns and moved the epic of heart
stop solution forward along with dr.
masseuse alwah and one of our epic
researchers sorry for the long-winded
answer but it really it really has been
a journey thanks dr. Carol now have you
studied the costs associated with Nats
versus two-step algorithm taking into
consideration the number of actual
negative tests where financial resources
would be utilized unnecessarily
um you know we try to get a health
economist involved in our project but I
don't think we were very successful it
would have been wonderful to have had
that individual join our team but
unfortunately I can't really speak to
that I apologize
how much additional work or time do you
spend answering calls for extra feet of
testing do you mean is part well can we
clarify a little bit so in terms of part
of the algorithm actually I question my
text this morning again originally we
were doing this we were getting wanted
to request to override the harsh hard
stops and give them the quote secret
code per day now we it's really dropped
off considerably it's more like wanted
to request per week so I think people
have just gotten used to it we hope we
hope that's the reason how did you
educate the clinicians before
implementation were there any complaints
um dr. Rock did a lot of education but
one of the wonderful things is we had we
have a high-value care committee here at
Johns Hopkins that looks not just at you
know see dip testing but looks at over
utilization of a broad range of other
tests including x-rays and other
radiologic studies and so we had House
staff buy-in we had those members of our
medical house staff who are very much
interested in high-value care and test
over utilization help with the
educational campaign we started with
putting the the pop-ups in epic first
before we implemented the hard stops in
order to educate people we did some
measurements around that and of course
due to alert fatigue most people
disregarded the pop-up not
not most but a significant number of
disregarded them although we did see a
drop it was not statistically
significant
dr. mrs. L will probably has more
information about this but we had we had
good buy-in from the House staff and
since it's mostly the House staff who
placed these orders I think that's the
reason it was successful why determined
the seven-day wait for retesting of
negative seed if this was based upon
several neighbors in the literature okay
now is it acceptable by IDSA guidelines
to perform the gdh toxin assay and to
report as negative when gdh positive
toxin gdh positive toxin negative
without reflecting to PCR yes yes
so the IDSA guidelines do allow you to
do a two-step or three-step algorithm so
yes okay and we looks like we have time
for just a few more this one's a little
longer with me in 2019 NHSN out of this
when using a multi-step testing
algorithm for CDI on the same unformed
stool specimen the finding of the last
test performed on the specimen that is
documented in the patient let's see all
right lost my place here documented in
the patient medical record will
determine if the CDI positive laboratory
assay
definition is met right this has led the
c-suite community to push for net first
and reflexive positives to free toxin
testing to reduce the number of NHSN
reportable lab I'd events yeah are you
aware of any NHSN or CMS discussions of
the promotion of this approach and is
and its effect on CDI rates in an
institution now unfortunately I don't
know the discussions that are occurring
but the person who framed this question
is absolutely correct and we've had I've
had enormous pressure to do this as well
although there isn't good consensus
among our clinical staff I do know that
that our infection control and folks
have tried to make the case at least
with NHSN that Hopkins should not be
penalized for using a sensitive single
test method when others are sort of
gaming the system by confirming their
NAT with a insensitive ew a test so it
is very has been very much brought to
the attention of well I should say CDC
through our infection control team and
we argue you know that we have improved
[Music]
you know test utilization to the point
where we we do feel that while we have
not completely eliminated you know poor
testing practices we certainly have
significantly reduced them so that is a
very good question and sums up exactly
the conundrum that faces labs that
really have studied this in their own
environment and prefer to use nat tests
combined with
some sort of computer decision report to
to improve testing and by the way I
think even though some of these other
test methods are insensitive it still
makes sense to try to reduce
inappropriate testing across the board
regardless of the test method that
you're using Thank You dr. Carroll now
dr. Carolyn dr. mrs. Salwa do either of
you have any final comments for our
audience I just want to thank everyone
for attending and hope we hope that this
was useful yeah I would also like to
thank you for your attention
I hope the information that we provide
it will be helpful for your practice
thank you again both of you for your
time today and your important research
and we'd also like to thank lab Rhodes
and our sponsor BV for underwriting
today's educational webcast now before
we go I would like to thank the audience
for joining us today and their
interesting questions again just a
reminder for those questions we did not
have time to answer today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
they will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on-demand and labret swil
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event a quick
survey will now pop up on your screen
and we approach we appreciate your
participation as it helps improve our
webinar program thanks again for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye